according to your site 95% of great
movies follow the story map I'm curious
what is a story map a story map is a
structural template that's followed by
most commercial films and it breaks a
story a film narrative into four acts
act 1 act 2 a act to be and act 3 and it
contains four major story engines that
drive each one of the individual acts
and eight to twelve major signpost plot
beats it's not deciding what you will
write it's providing a form and a
template with which the writer pours
their story into so a writer still makes
their own unique creative decisions but
they may want to think about what page
ranges those decisions fall in and the
kind of basic beats that would inform
the storytelling okay where do you think
many new writers go wrong in terms of
the map in terms of the layout what
where most new writers weak in that
structure often it's over writing to the
point where those beats are falling too
late like I mentioned the inciting
incident should probably be between a 8
to page 8 to 12 but we also want
something that I call the strong
movement forward that the next major
beat to be in the page 18 to 20 range
sometimes that doesn't happen until 28
and then the true end of act 1 which
should be around page 30 is in the
beginner script not happening until page
38 and that really makes the reader
anxious and slows down the pace of the
story and the structure so it's not
hitting the proper page ranges again
this isn't deciding what you should
write but it's deciding of basically
what page range is the major beats
should be how you should tell the story
to some extent okay kind of that outer
frame of the story with which you're
pouring your unique unique decisions
into but as far as mistake
there is a major signpost bead falling
too early too late or just not being
there for example there's a beat that I
call the assumption of power or
declaration of war beat and this should
have been around page 75 and you can see
it in movies it happens around minute 75
if that's not there if there's not that
moment where this character really feels
their true power and acts in a way that
makes them rise to the occasion and kind
of a declaration of war or an attack and
a declaration of intent and something
that taps their inner strength if that's
not happening in that page range I don't
think the story is necessarily moving as
it should interesting is there an
example of a film or two you could just
tell us about like when that moment is
that's fascinating to me
yeah the what I call the declaration of
war slash assumption of power beat is
around page 75 in a screenplay and
minute 75 in a film so a classic example
would be in the Karate Kid the show me
paint house moment show me paint the
fence show me Sand the floor and it's
that moment at which Daniel Larusso
realizes he's been learning karate all
along even though mr. Miyagi has been
making him do all his chores so he asked
him to show him the the positions that
he's put his hands as he's been doing
these chores and it turns out he's been
learning karate this whole time so he
really Daniel really realizes his true
power realizes he can do karate and he's
doing it already so when you go back to
read scripts that you can tell her from
a more seasoned writer you say that you
just see it as a tighter in terms of
when you know say that inciting incident
pages 8 through 10 or it's just it's a
more on the nose load it flows okay
right and then you can tell maybe
someone who's more of a green rider baby
writer by the fact that it's it's looser
receiver
it's either farther push down or too
soon or so
yes overwritten scenes are too long they
drag on too long you have those QA
sessions of dialogue those Talking Heads
scenes where there's just too much on
the nose dialogue the scene isn't moving
forward you want every scene to advance
the story to explore the controlling
theme or reveal crucial character okay
it has to advance the story so
definitely that first one it has to do
in some way and then ideally it will
also be on theme that major theme that
central theme that this particular story
is exploring and then third does it
reveal some crucial character you know
something that we haven't seen before
about this particular character so what
about the school of thought where people
say you know it doesn't have to be so on
the nose and then there's others that
are like yes it does well what's your
take on that because we do get our like
page points yeah yeah some people really
debate that and they feel really
controlled by that but it sounds like
it's it's incredibly important because
the reader or the viewer will lose
interest I think it is you know I think
structure is very important in hitting
those page points is important if for no
other reason because every reader and
Hollywood has internalized that
structure but I mean the real proof in
the pudding is that when you read Pro
scripts buy produce writers buy the top
writers in Hollywood who are making the
top money they use this structure so
there has to be something about it that
is the reason why the first act of a
movie is around 30 minutes there's
something there there's some reason why
that works
you